you probably thought i was going to
start with this
but i do want to bring this up because i
i got to tell you now i'm not just
i probably shouldn't even say this to
you
i shouldn't even say this to you because
i don't know how you're going to receive
it
do
i hope michael smith
you will receive this with humility that
you will take this and remain humble
all right
let's be honest
always
all right so i have read
uh a lot of a lot of the smart the
basketball intelligentsia
on this whole lebron
and how his greatness what does number
four mean
uh i've listened to former players
i've i've looked at the stats the
advanced stats analytics the whole thing
and i still some really compelling
reporting some compelling writing
michael smith but
i still think you got the best take on
it after all the stuff i've looked at i
think you've got the best take
on lebron versus okay let's not dance
around it lebron versus michael jordan
you know a shot there everybody keep
bringing it up we don't want to bring it
up but it keeps coming up
you your take on lebron versus michael
jordan was the best one and it really
does
it it answers the question it is
what's your preference nobody wants to
hear that but you mentioned stevie
wonder versus prince
two
completely transcendent artists
with two completely different styles who
do you like who do you prefer
and that's really what it comes down to
with with michael jordan and and lebron
james and i know a lot of people don't
really want to hear that because they
want closure to this argument but they
don't know they want an answer
they want to show everyone exposure to
this
you care
well i guess you can but but know that
when you're picking one
that it's not definitive hey i'm picking
jordan and that answers
that settles the argument you pick your
one you're not settling the argument
you're starting it
and it's a continuation
of an ongoing
discussion that will probably never be
resolved
because
that six and oh can't be six 6-0 can't
be a drop drop the mic moment right
because if you're going to do that
if you're going to go 6-0 in the finals
right then if i come back and go 11-2 in
the finals
then you
might come back and say well that was a
different era
so right it can't be it can't be just
championships that can't be it or i mean
or six and no in the finals versus five
and four eleven and two by the way it's
bill russell bill russell for those of
you no no no yeah
yeah but 6-0 in the finals versus five
and four magic
you know versus
uh
ten finals trips but continue i don't
wanna interrupt i'm just saying like
there's something to be said for going
that many times you know what i mean you
may have lost
but there's a lot to be said for going
but i didn't want i don't want to
interrupt your train of thought because
i got no i was out for you but go ahead
no let it kill because i want i want to
uh go down the court and just go back
and forth on this because one of the
things that but i'm enjoying you giving
me my props so so don't don't stop
giving me my problems all right
that's it give me more i'm just saying
i'm just saying of all the smart guys
i've heard out there yours is still just
like the smartest
you you summarized it you summarized it
you synthesized all these different
threads you put it all together
but you know mike it occurs to me that
some of this is generational now i'm not
saying if you're if you're 23 years old
you're automatically going to say lebron
is better than michael jordan but some
of it if you just think about the whole
the whole argument of lebron versus
jordan some of it is
well
lebron
left
he left he didn't stay loyal to that
team that picked him he had to go and
search
for for his championships now if you're
if you're of that mind
if you if you if you feel that way
you're always going to go with jordan
but then another way of looking at it
mike is
hey some of the the wall has been broken
down between
general managing
and
super starring if i can invert invent a
term
so
it used to be when jordan jordan didn't
have that option they weren't even
thinking like that it would the the
the collective bargaining agreement
wasn't designed that way
in the in the late 80s and early 90s
when michael jordan could say if he were
so inclined hey you know what i'm gonna
do this i'm gonna go forget forget about
jerry krause forget about these general
managers i'm gonna be the general
manager and i'm gonna put together my
own squad
yeah but
michael uh
but lebron james that's just kind of
that's kind of what he does and that's a
that's a modern thing that's not a big
deal
in 2020 it was unheard of in 1993 that
people just didn't do that
so that's one of them the other thing
mike is
michael michael jordan was always a
scorer he was always a scorer you never
had to tell him hey the game won a line
score
so by the time he got to the finals he
was a complete he was a complete player
in his first finals appearance
against the lakers in 1991 he was a
complete player already
lebron was a dynamic player but in his
first finals appearance versus the spurs
he was not complete yet he almost had
this how strange this is he almost had
to be taught
to become more selfish
because you know his instinct
is just to hey what is what am i going
to do what's best for the game and
michael jordan's like hey game
last
10 seconds
i don't care what it is most of the time
i'm taking the shot now i'll pass it off
every now and then but you don't have to
tell me to take over this game because
that's really what i'm wired to do
so you know what's interesting
it just occurred to me
do you remember pre 1991 with the wrap
on jordan was and it's something that
nobody ever said about lebron it was
that jordan couldn't make his teammates
better
it's laughable looking back but he
couldn't make his teammates better which
lebron was always the guy that made
everybody better um i appreciate you um
i appreciate you appreciating
uh what i had to say about the uh
ongoing lebron versus jordan debate and
i'm actually going to reciprocate that
because i came into this
crediting something that you said
recently
for my uh lebron take
today
because we had a we had an argument
along these lines you may remember when
you said that
um
jordan or
bird or magic or korean that they could
never do
what lebron has done and i took
exception with the word could
they didn't right as you just laid out a
minute ago they didn't but i didn't like
that you said that they couldn't
but the fact that that's michael you
know mike i don't remember arguments i
don't hold grudges like that no no no
wait but
fact is no no no look
this is i'm actually
i'm actually agreeing with you on the
fact of the matter is
that nobody else did
with three different teams
right kareem won it with two different
teams
was finals mvp with two different teams
kawhi leonard has done it with two
different teams it was finals i mean
people two different teams you could
argue whether or not he was the actual
leader of that spurs team that he won
the finals mvp with
part of reason he won finals mvp
remember it was a thing when guys would
win for stopping or slowing down lebron
high andre iguodala right
um
and shaq won it with two different teams
went with three different teams but one
with two different teams went with the
magic lakers and heat one with the last
two
but there's one guy now
there's one guy who can say
and this is lebron's 6-0
this is lebron's 11 rings there's only
one guy who can say
i have gone
and won the finals and finals mvp with
three different franchises
michael let me say it to you like this
it's not supposed to be as easy as
lebron james makes it look
right
his presence in the finals
is a given it's a constant
he goes to the finals every year
and for him to change
situations
change franchises
and they give back year after year and
to now say that he's the first and only
guy to win finals mvp for three
different franchises that is such a
singular and monumental accomplishment
until you know what lebron is right
when he said give me my damn respect he
was like what you need you know what he
doesn't get enough respect i'm not
saying he's underrated but he doesn't
get enough respect because the only
thing easy about what lebron james is
doing is taking it for granted
let me say that again yeah the only
thing easy about what lebron james is
doing is taking it for granted it's
think about all the great players in nba
history
who never win a championship
and who might have gotten to the finals
once
charles barkley got to the finals one
time
carl malone got to the finals two times
dude's been 10 times
with three different teams
and been the best player in the series
with three different teams four times
now only he and jordan have four regular
season mvps and four finals mvps
dude has averaged 25 points 10 rebounds
and five assists in the finals
six times half dozen times it's nuts the
other people who do it have only done it
once
and so
it's still a matter of preference
but i'll actually give credit so i'm
giving credit to you for pointing out
that lebron james has done something
that not many others could do but we
know for sure nobody else has actually
done it which is be the guy on three
different teams for three different
finals but i'll just give credit to one
other person
and honestly and maybe somebody else has
said it that's mark jackson
mark jackson
because he said it again last night
lebron may
with in another couple of years i think
he's playing like this
another couple of years he'll pass
kareem
for
maybe not a couple of years maybe long i
don't know what the math is
he's on track on course to pass kareem
as the all-time leading scorer
possibly in the lakers uniform
in another two years if my math is right
he'll pass magic johnson
on the assist shark in a lakers uniform
let's say he adds
another couple of titles
to his resume
and i'll get a resume in a second but i
just want to make this last point before
i pass it back to you
he may not be the greatest player ever
for some people
but as mark jackson has said he'll have
the greatest career
of all time
interesting i think it's arguably he
could he could end up having the
greatest career may not have the most
rings
but if you put the points with the
assist and all the other
counting stats
the
the consistency
along with the championships
he he might have the greatest career
when it's all said and done and again
that's mark jackson is sitting
looking at it looking at the fact that
that's that that singular achievement of
being a guy that's
wanted three times
one finals mvp with three different
teams
that's it's just not supposed to be that
hard or easy excuse me it's not supposed
to be that easy it's supposed to be hard
to get to the finals and then think
about it like the people were talking
about there was a level of consistency
to their organization to their
supporting casts
to their coaches
to their surroundings
to the more things change with him the
more things stay the same and he ends up
on top at the end of the day
well well two quick things two quick
things
and then we've got to get to somebody
who you got to go on the three-way we
gotta get on the three-way know somebody
talk to somebody who knows a lot about
uh the lakers and history and
championships well that's coming up in a
couple seconds but uh two quick things
the reason
lebron james
his performance is taken for granted in
the finals
is because when he leaves those teams
you just assume that
great players playing together will get
to the finals
he's always done it
but as we know from those odds we're
looking at those odds clippers next year
we know that's not always the case just
because great players play together
doesn't mean they're going to make it to
the finals and win them now that's
always happened with him whether whether
they've won or not if lebron james is on
your team
you're pro at bare minimum you're going
to win 50 games in a normal nba season
that's bare minimum 50 games second
round of the playoffs got it you're not
going to be eliminating the first round
you're going to win 50 you're going to
get to the second round but you're
probably going to the finals
but ask the clippers
kawhi leonard and paul george this year
back in the day charles barkley uh and
scottie pippen on the same team okay
didn't work out ask the lakers that
super team had lost two two other
pistons in 2004 you got you know carl
malone and gary payton and kobe and shaq
it doesn't always happen that way and so
we assume oh this is just easy no he
makes it to your point he makes it look
easy and my final point my final point
is you said he's the first guy to win a
championship with three different teams
he's also going to be the first guy to
win multiple championships with three
different teams because he's not done
well he's only got down here with like
two we're two different teams well two
were two different teams yeah i mean he
didn't do it he didn't wear multiple
with cleveland but you know i get your
point it will multiple with two miami
uh let's sneak in this break yo did you
see brady's tweet though this is how you
turn a frown upside down you got it gary
that's gangster
shout out to gilad in shadow line but
that's gangster
you